[Music]
[Music]
madonna's firstborn is entering the
family biz what's a good lola story
the queen of pop's daughter lola leone
drops her debut single lock and key
along with a gothic inspired music video
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
and lola whose real name is lourdes is
taking on yet another moniker she's
kicking off her next chapter with the
stage name lola hall she's got my eyes
and my mouth
and my round face
and she has a very strong will which is
something both of us have
fast forward to 2022 madonna can add
music to the list
[Music]
yeah apparently madge had some thoughts
about lola's next chapter in an
interview last year lola revealed mom's
words of wisdom quote she's very much
like proceed with caution and think
about what you want to be known for well
it's everything happens
pretty organically as she tells it
lola's ready to expand her horizons
after a few years on the catwalk
my mom is very insistent on making me
think about what i want to be known for
beyond my looks that's not what i want
people to remember me by it's not real
it's like super fun to be able to like
like watch something be creative and
like see the finishing like the results
yeah madonna's always encouraged her
kids to chase their dreams back in 2010
she even collabed with lola on a fashion
line i'm very proud of her of course and
i just i i don't i want all my kids to
be creative but whatever they end up
doing is fine with me like my mom has
helped me so much she like she has great
style she's an amazing dresser
no arguments here we're just happy to
see they've come a long way since lola's
terrible twos she's very manipulative
whenever i ask her to give me a kiss she
tells me to cry first
so
i don't know where she got that from
[Music]
you